on the surface and see coulis is quietly
getting on with her life still behind
the wheel still in her neighborhood in
Virginia she may be a wanted woman but
her government the Trump administration
won't give her up
she's charged with causing the death of
Harry Dunne by dangerous driving after
the crash near RAF Croton in
Northamptonshire
she claimed diplomatic immunity and
returned to America Harry's family met
with their MP Andrea led 'some after she
told them that extradition had been
blocked by the u.s. she has to come back
I don't I still don't understand how she
can even live with herself and carry on
with her life and drive she always if
the US side was hoping that you might
run out of steam as it were what would
you say to that
no chops simple really is that simple
answer Kulas admits she was driving on
the wrong side of the road that simple
mistake has left two close allies at
loggerheads over what should happen to
her it is a test of both the US and UK
government and stuck in the middle of
this rail is a grieving yet determined
family who made a promise to their son
as he lay dying that they would never
give up fighting for justice in a
statement the Foreign Secretary Dominic
Robb said I called the US ambassador
earlier to express the government's
disappointment about this decision
we feel this amounts to a denial of
justice and we believe ance Akula should
return to the UK we are now urgently
considering our options but the US says
granting extradition would set a
troubling precedent
mrs. Letson said she too had had a frank
discussion with the US ambassador I've
expressed my disappointment on behalf of
Harry's family but also really
importantly for the local community in
this instant
the fact that there is no justice for
Harry makes the pain of losing him so
much worse the family's hope is that
strong words from the UK government will
be followed by action they are prepared
for a long fight
lissa dad Sky News Northamptonshire